okay I just hopped off the treadmill because I had to respond to this
because this is the conversation that needs to be had
no mother who is sympathizing with the woman with the 17 diapers
is saying that an environment with 17 dirty diapers is healthy for an infant
no one saying that it should not be the standard
however the conversation that is having
and the conversation that is so much more important
than how many dirty diapers were in her house
is how we get to this point
as women and mothers and caretakers
how women have these babies are left to emotionally and physically drown
until there are physical tells of how bad they're doing
that's when people pay attention
and instead of paying attention for it being a symptom of a larger problem
um they only look at the symptom
which could be dirty diapers
which could be postpartum depression
which could be a mental breakdown
and then shame the mom for having those problems
17 dirty diapers is a symptom of a larger
more dangerous problem with maternal mental health
and that's why that should be the focus of the conversation that we're having
not whether or not 17 diapers is disgusting
cause it's bigger than that
the conversation is bigger than that
if we keep focusing on the 17 diapers or the mental breakdown
or the woman who hasn't showered in three weeks
we are gonna miss the opportunity to actually make change
and actually help people and I agree
the baby's other parent very important part of this conversation
but that is not the only person
who is supposed to make up the village for the new mother